[Music]
30-plus years of service combat medals
citations only man to shoot down three
enemy planes in last 40 years that you
can't get a promotion won't retire
despite your best efforts he refused to
die
you should be at least a two-star
admiral by now yet here you are captain
what is that it's one of life's
mysteries sir
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the end is inevitable maverick you kind
of said it for extinction
maybe so sorry but not today
[Music]
Oh God hey pasa man you're just sorry
just you in that chair
I think Gautam a damn fine president you
would have brought a real dignity to the
office you're welcome America
welcome to Zombieland life is about more
than just survival we were a family
dysfunctional sure but what family isn't
very good what would you like little
girl I really like for you to stop
calling me little girl but you know what
I would like I don't give a [ __ ] what
you it felt so good to be on the move
again oh my god I'm so sorry hi I'm
Columbus nothing this is tell AHA see
hey poplar this your dad
Oh whoopsie I forgot this he felt wrong
oh so she knows the rules I told her
just a few of her 7300 and are there
more they're cute
I like it mister is callin she picked up
the boy he's from Berkeley Berkeley even
that we'd do you do I look like the type
of person that would have weed I'm sorry
boom ya have nothing against it be SOT
just wanna beat the [ __ ] out of we're
gonna go get her we're at it darling
start talking you first
[Music]
[Music]
that's my ride oh my apologies little
Elvis is it me or does he kind of remind
you of I don't like you at all
I think you double-parked Oh more
perpendicular parks hope we don't get it
is going on here what hello everyone
bye Liz Nina
[Music]
we have excellent news the matchmaker
has found you an auspicious match it is
two-sided come and sit down
[Music]
it is what is best for our family
[Music]
yes I will Briana trowel
quiet
[Music]
come post
graceful
[Music]
dissipate
[Music]
are the Korky
[Music]
are the qualities
[Music]
it is my duty to fight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
throughout time our people robbed lied
and killed until one day we found
ourselves noblemen but that nobility
never came from chivalry it came from
being tough and ruthless
[Music]
the real power is not found running off
to war
the real power lies in understanding who
it is you're truly fighting
[Music]
and how they can be defeated
[Music]
I know you want to fight but there are
other ways of doing your duty come on
still talking to your friends it's
complicated
many ideas when we first got together we
were different people the game grandpa
hey Anthony
this is a Martha and Bethany this is
very nice to meet you
morning sorry to barge in on you you're
not barging he's barging my little
Walker yeah did you guys see Spencer
think he went back in we gotta go
huh
what oh you oh my god you're Spencer's
grandfather
are we in Florida and you my little
Walker did I die and turn into some kind
of a small muscular boy scout are we
dead I'm fat do my show it feels good
now look at my thighs okay we have some
issues here the game is busted
who's the game I'm not yet I don't
wonder yet welcome to Jumanji
this next venture is even more
challenging now remember the future of
Jumanji is in your hands
I have one important question who is
Jumanji as that barbers boy we're gonna
do we did are we in hell and
the whole thing
you've got to have eyes in the back in
the same
what the hell is to suit your strengths
and weaknesses smoldering intensity it's
a stupid face you make huh
he's going on you having a heart attack
breathe breathe this whole left side is
shutting down any stories don't witches
[Music]
see to mother say
elves are the original sorcerers of the
continent but humans a monsters arrival
else took you miss how to turn chaos
into magic the humans looked at them
chaos is the most dangerous thing in
this world but without control chaos
will kill you
so that's all like this to you months
doesn't manage it's all it needs to me
something out there weights me
this child will be extraordinary
Jennifer imagine the most powerful woman
in the world
do you have what it takes
you can't outrun destiny just because
you're terrified of it it's coming
I can't do this without you
no matter what you choose
we'll come out bloody
five years ago I thought I lost you
forever
there is no curse that could ever tell
me away from you will you marry me yes
[Music]
[Music]
fishes have a little bit of news don't
ruin my morning
there have asked me to marry him no I
wasn't really asking nor was I love
doesn't always end well beasty trust me
let us prove you wrong you have done an
admirable job going against your own
nature to raise this child but now she
will finally get the love of a real
mother tonight I consider Aurora my own
what have you done we go home now
Aurora
Maleficent is a threat to everyone
because you are best at
help
[Applause]
one can never be too careful
you
you do not know me
tell me what happened there was another
creature you've spent years caring for a
shoe
now it's time to careful your own
[Music]
gentlemen we are smokejumpers the most
elite team of firefighters in the world
we must be at our very best for
extraction
so we can get you back to your parents
I'm legally bound to take care yet so
that's why I'm gonna do an intern you're
gonna be obedient it's a we can do our
job and when you do this when you when
you go like oh like that it's not
helpful
Michigan's under my watch we buy your
man can't turn my neck what needs to
happen this second is you got to watch
your tone little sister or what masher
is coming to rock you or what just
happened I think the baby just broke it
dog suit Big Daddy I get distracted I
can't do this job effectively don't you
remember what it's like to be a kid did
we kill you
well now it's a party
what kind of firefighters are you I know
you don't see it but he has a sweet side
what a rush
boom boom what's boom don't look at me
so don't do it around
[Music]
hey I'm Fred Rogers in here it's a
beautiful day in this neighborhood a
beautiful day for a neighbor
would you be mine could you be mine
please believe me
my neighbor
hello neighbor mr. Rogers I'm here to
interview you it is so nice to meet you
okay hold on mr. Rogers Lloyd please
don't ruin my childhood this piece will
be for an issue about heroes do you
consider yourself a hero we are trying
to get the world positive ways of
dealing with feelings
[Music]
yeah like what
many things you can do
you can play all the lowest keys on a
piano at the same time
[Music]
you love broken people
like me
sometimes we have to ask for help
and that's okay
I think the best thing we can do is to
let people know
[Music]
that each one of them is preface
mr. Rogers sum was like I was seeing her
ghost like every trigger I've ever
pulled
how'd he start you hunting birds rabbit
guessing 19 20 years old the first time
he ordered you to shoot a person
25 years ago he took my blood
made you from me
is the lion to you the whole time told
you you were an orphan and all the
people in the world to come after me why
would he send you
because I'm the best you are obviously
not the best and just trying to rattle
me trying to save you you made a choice
to do this to me
the whole point of this thing was to
give you all of Henry's gifts without
his pain I don't wanna shoot you mind if
I shoot you
hey is this ever having you before your
own government trying to kill you wow
that's new everything that we've worked
for is a stake he has to die is your
darkness you had to walk through this on
your own I love you Junior
look what we created
you were the inspiration for all of us
when I just make a whole army full of
them why not you should be flattered you
should be dead
this has to be stopped
because what if somebody actually know
what we really are
welcome to my arena face your challenges
they're the serious version of the box
just what we need to take us up a notch
let's prove we are the best Titans in
the multiverse
so I think I know who's behind this
hi there that's right we will conquer
the multiverse together and there's
nothing you can do to stop us we are in
the danger it is time for the
collaboration oh come on
oh wow yeah we're all besties now
Oh what took you so long
Santa Claus
is this good or bad
the cost of being a hero brooding heroes
there Robin is so handsome
[Music]
Titans go
[Music]
I'm detective lieutenant Elliot and this
is trooper Wagner we just want to ask a
few questions
we understand none of his demise the
family have gathered to celebrate your
father's 85th birthday how was it hello
the party pre my dad's death it was
great ladies and gentlemen I would like
to request that you all stay until the
investigation is completed
what can we ask why has something
changed no no it hasn't changed or no we
can't ask one of his family walls is
that what you're suggesting
[Music]
love twisting the knife into one another
up your ass
oh very perfect oui chef how's that
eat [ __ ] [ __ ] definitely eat [ __ ]
you know something spill it
I suspect foul play
I have eliminated no suspects
it's a twisted web we are not finished
untangling it not yet
what is this CSI KFC you know you can
tell when you're the world's greatest
spy surely everyone knows the name
[Music]
don't take the law so hard I mean you
got to meet lance sterling
[Music]
thank you thank you - is too much it's
probably the right amount still go back
to working at home it is gonna change
spying forever
it's called biodynamic concealment
imagine if I can make you wait for it
bro please disappear disappear disappear
why are you saying it like that for a
fact that next generation concealment
tech you wouldn't happen to have it on
hand would you
I do happen to have it in hand show it
to me sure um what can I offer you a
drink I got water drinkable meal
replacement mmm we had a drink Wow diet
stuff has a weird aftertaste
what's the tech um
[Music]
it worked
subject appears disoriented what did you
do Lance
look at me look at you I can't not look
at you Walter I can see my butt and your
face at the same time everywhere nobody
notices them girl it's the most perfect
flawless spy could take I'm gonna unburn
me right now that's it I'm gonna play
with you I'm Bert I'm raising my voice I
probably shouldn't be raising my voice
at you I need you to unburnt me Walter
you booted yourself or just trying to
build little bits of the puzzle what do
you remember about the incident I like
this one look at the map where were you
when it happened I don't remember well
you came around
did you see people yes
what were they doing
they were dead we are an awful lot like
Theo oh we both went through
the sooner we get back to a normal
routine the better
[Music]
all right that Blackwell said he sent me
exactly where I needed to be into who I
needed to be with his mother dead to
yes
I knew you were there and I know what
else was in that room
the goldfish before and after everything
is before and after in the middle is the
painting
that's life
ruphylin miracle after miracle it
survives there's something important
I've to tell you
until you
they lost
[Music]
even the tiniest things mean something
[Applause]
who took the pain
rocket forever
[Music]
maybe sometimes good can come from bed
[Music]
who's my fault she died
I would have given it back I swear
[Music]
some people believe if we repeat stories
often enough they become real they make
us who we are that can be scary eat it
Harold do you want to see haunted house
some kids went missing so they boarded
it up
okay I saw it we go now for the chicken
[Music]
what's that it's a book of scary stories
tell me a story
hey what's going on
Tommy's missing Tommy's name was in the
book there's no way it's actually
connected right okay what is what
happens in the book is exactly what's
happened for real oh my god listen
you're in the next story reading it
right here
[Music]
I'm afraid that we broke something up
we've got to stop it
sara bellows his book when the stories
write themselves and it all comes alive
the jingling man is coming
[Music]
something to happens to you when you
leave this town far the way the hazy er
it all gets the me and I've left I
remember all of it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to the losers we made an oath I swear if
it isn't dead
if it ever comes back
we'll come back to we didn't stop it we
can't let it happen again
[Music]
27 years
I dreamt of you I craved you
[Music]
I missed you
we need to finish
[Music]
it consumes us from the inside until we
don't have a choice
[Music]
[ __ ] tops 8 we're still a team yours
why would he they responded to a robbery
people gonna Rob 660 pounds of coke
do you drive a BMW door to the job you
bring just one other guy with you did
you only take 50 keys to see the dumb
lot or set up
to shoot us automatic weapons settings
Attila to killer
and refused
to allow these families to be
traumatized with trials and appeals and
parole hearings I'm asking you to
protect them from that I understand
everything about these guys has been
company so far close the island for
Island man at the 21 bridges and shut
him down three rivers closing 14 yeah
version of this where these two are
found
none of this makes sense it's going on
here and switch on see ya
these cops were there to see that
actively dislikes them
the city they still protect with their
lives I just need the truck you go down
this road you're on your own
the sword in pain cops or criminals or
your heads
I will find you
I couldn't sleep that night I remember
thinking I'm all alone and then I
realized I had nothing to hide
there you are
I just decided I wasn't gonna be afraid
[Music]
when they assigned her to me it was my
idea to send her to Iran get her into
the nuclear division her cover an
English and French teacher I probably
not gonna sleep tonight I'm gonna do
great you're the best person for this
assignment did you know she was pricking
she had no idea Rachel what do you do
haven't you learned not to ask questions
like that the people here all have many
secrets you're gonna tell me what's
going on
she disappeared disappeared she could be
anywhere now we couldn't control her she
wanted to make that point
there's much more going on I'll handle
it I don't think you should get into
this need to find a way to bring him
here what is going on
you wouldn't understand and follow your
protocol assuming you know everything
but you don't this is war and in war
people die
[Music]
are you pulling me out not
times change
you do what you gotta do some kids most
employers don't want mothers it's a
competitive market you don't know me
the money
you survive now might be the time
so what feel my husband's 24 months left
other senses sorry baby
this is divers mom organized crime we're
gonna take care of you you gonna be just
fully we got no money can't even make
the rent with what they gave him last
night they didn't want me in the family
in the first place
forty years they pay protection away
don't get nothing for it
they have been homeless for effort that
we are never gonna do anything but have
babies bunch of men that have forgotten
what family means so we remind them no
pretty mama pretty doesn't man was just
a tool women use what anything we want
what do you want I can see you got
brains and I know you got money but we
got one thing that you don't criminals
so you can't go around was it for a
bunch of women you're not smarter than
I was like you are the face of the earth
I don't want you to start I want you to
teach me how to it
just to be clear now we run this
neighborhood
[Music]
step off my business baby my business
left they're gonna swallow this entire
city you go to war
there's no coming back also karate wants
to talk if we go to Brooklyn we're dead
what are you where does something like
that get dressed up kitty
my god I lost count again
[Music]
[Music]
good morning woman where am I you're in
paradise of course what is this place
this is an opportunity
[Music]
if you could learn your place you of
your best years out of you
our family sent us here to shape us in
their image
you're in our brave new world
it's about owning your story who you
truly are
what were helped to change of your
there's always a way to get what you
want I'm getting out of here
every night they make us sleep like
we're dead
[Music]
it's as if that girl never existed
I'll find you
[Music]
[Music]
when those seats are filled and when the
lights go down there's that moment
suspended in time we're waiting for the
magic to begin
[Music]
they cut you all I need is a shot you
guys ever need a piano player not in 30
years
Yuri is our choreographer sander reigns
you missed a ton I don't need to see it
again I can do the turn fine
on audition for your show it works it's
Delhi
[Music]
we need a saws under dawn says the star
I can't put that on the marquee okay
I'll sign the deal she'll be starring in
free dance
I need you to help me with her to make
this show work there's one called backup
dancers cuz they're always one step
behind the star I need to show to be
certain I'm lonely brilliant I want that
too she's phenomenal what exactly is
going on between the hands and her so
she bared her soul out there for you
today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're strong you're very talented prove
yourself
[Music]
so how would you feel about going to the
mountains for Christmas with grace she
really wants to get to know you guys
that's our mom's hat Wow okay I don't
want to leave you here with the kids if
you're not feeling I'm talking I'm
feeling fine
it was my idea and it's a couple days I
can do a couple days okay guys a mom fun
what is that that's crazy
everyone committed suicide a sinner
repent and you will find salvage things
are very uncomfortable opportunist we're
stuck in a house together
[Music]
what is this the power's out where are
my things it makes no sense
what I heard something
hello did you do that we didn't do
anything
[Applause]
we're leaving what are you talking about
look outside we're stuck here
[Music]
okay
trust me
you have nothing to be scared about
this is major Roy McBride I'm attempting
to reach dr. Clifford McBride this is
dr. McBride son
dad I'd like to see Union
[Music]
I've recall how we used to watch black
my movies together musicals were your
favorite
I remember you tutoring me in math
[Music]
instilled in me a strong work ethic
you should know I've chosen a career
that you would approve of I've dedicated
my life to the exploration of space and
I thank you for that
[Music]
what is happening out there is a crisis
of unknown magnitude
[Music]
we believe your father may be involved
my father's dead what exactly are you
required for me
exploration is now is a noble venture
we have to hold out the possibility that
your father may be hiding from us
[Music]
we have a job to do are you ready I'm
ready
[Music]
some heroes are unshakable others are
unstoppable
but only one chi is part of a portable
10 piece set
Rex Tasha at your service for your next
mission we're partnering you with two
civilians well play this this was just
garbage over the last several months a
top secret organization has caused
citizens from different lands to vanish
into thin air that's not good I need you
two to help rescue them we're running
out of time
danger or anything like I'm 100% almost
sure
[Applause]
this entire city is guarded day time to
go save the world
[Applause]
that was terrifying but also kind of
exhilarating
rikes
I know you love me you don't need to say
um I was just gonna say you forgot your
sunglasses
tell the boss tells here to see her I
got a Dell down here asking to see Miss
cheat no not Adele that was Shawn's back
but there's a new arrival in town
Lola he's a little alien she's about to
discover that our world is pretty sweet
[Music]
[Music]
but she's far from home and in big
trouble to help her get back Billy to
outsmart the bad guys
be prepared stay focused and stick to
the plan let the creators of chicken run
take you on an adventure that's out of
this world get ready for a close
encounter of the Third Kind
Farmageddon a Shaun the Sheep movie
[Music]
[Music]